yo whats up guys its prestige here today
and where am i man this is the new mess
up I own for the 1.7 point 1 1.7 point
oh that was backwards on 1.7 point to
update and i will be doing a survival
series just going through probably each
of the new biomes of this yeah that's
good Oh cute the music nice yeah there
are multiple new biomes and I'm just
going to be doing little snippets of
them each through the course of survival
so for survival let's go ahead and make
my game mode at 0 I do a piece on that
it's pretty chill relax thing to the
music or stop come on bro what the music
stopped so yeah we're just going to get
right into it so let's go now I gonna
have me I don't think this what is
normal worthless II don't know just
output so this is the mess up i own this
is the first 1i found actually you guys
want this seed for this it's gonna be on
the screen and now two three four sevens
have nine to 1750 1329 1886 i think i
might have missed a digit in there but
hopefully not so yeah we're just gonna
get to making a house with all this play
and i must say this message by ohm
survival thing looks pretty nice so tell
you people any other people that are not
watching this video as a new person and
their subscribers all by doing these
series will keep me going for a little
bit so now I just ended the harbin
series and so we'll find out what I will
plant that and ooh taking inventory I
just earned the achievement all ready
they completely like rehal the
achievement system in this so that's
cool so let's make ourselves a crafting
table
and let's get to craft and all right so
sticks and then let me a pic i have a
set survival thing always what I do for
survival so we're gonna want to break
through this can we make can we make
anything with hardened clay let's see a
hardened clay want to make hardly sword
oh no I didn't work alright so we're
going to go way oh dang so then I'm just
gonna keep gonna be hitting more clay
huh I just normal clay dang it wait that
stone that's not snow just clay I think
that's one thing that's bad about this
biome just clay with the heck like gray
stained clay ok this is not gonna work
let's try going over here it's not we
hope oh is it just gonna be just gonna
be like like that out ok let's go hit up
a pocket of stone since this isn't
working so yeah so let's go way over
here yeah but but it but if it is there
is any of the stone I almost like this
biome does look awesomely fantastic
however I don't know like in this bottom
you they even have any stone so like
this is the bottom oh I think this is
the bottom layer so this is just red
sand that's cool different types hand
but can we get some stone up in here and
I don't want to make something I won't
make them stone tools bro oh they're
seriously like me any stone oh it's like
a rabun well there's stone of this my
own they don't like completely eradicate
it that's good all right now we can get
herself some stone good this whoa what
is the noises oh no pain I'm guessing
cool down there too however there are a
lot of little mothy mothy so I didn't
probably not gonna want to go down there
hello creeper sup yeah that's one of the
reasons I don't want to go down there so
we definitely begin ton of clay and I
think I can
make some good ol like it makes some of
those good i don't think that creeper
can get some it you can't get to me
that's good i'm all one week some
cool-ass that's going to be a different
thing so each of these biomes are gonna
have a short little survival series and
yep i might care over my stuff from
previous places yeah thing i'm going to
do that to each like cumulative
cumulative place i get to scale up nope
nope okay we palin Balin okay we good
and we have the crafting table so we can
crap ourselves a ton of tool I don't
think I need that many I need some more
there we go ten should do it alright so
we're going to want two pics come on
there we go on ax shift-click why's this
shift-click networking a shovel and a
sword to finish it all off so that was a
bit longer than my normal stuff is but
my normals basic setup to get my basic
set of tools but oh well art so we're
gonna want to get household as I'm
Danielle pick up some more of this red
sand and I guess I'll come down here
whenever I only get some cobble some too
so we can make a house I don't make a
house up clay it's all these what I'm
going to do so that's destroying you
stuff I think I have a good amount of
hardened clay I just don't have that
much this is white sing play yeah and I
oh and I've just enough to make a
furnace that's what I'm talking about
that is what I'm talking about booper
dooper do PGD and let's go let's
continue travelling up
and pick up some brown on the way up oh
yes I'll take you brown I have no racism
towards the Browns okay like it's like
the name of like a football team I'll
totally get some yellow live and place
up a bit then you're just more some gray
gray is no fun one looks gray gave
hissing light it some light okay okay
now we can start moving up all right all
right so let's see do we have any email
issue that that that music is a bit loud
music and sound music volume right there
the music no master volume was half full
music I just had 250 even though it
still gonna be like allowed for 15 days
longer because it just it's loud forever
alright we're obviously gonna need some
wood getting wood but up but I already
got what the heck music sound go down
two more but but i already had gotten
would I I don't know what let's look at
my achievements options or the
achievements achievements achievements
achievement will do normal achievements
so get wood okay bench work like I do I
have to get that also I feel like remake
but I can remake my sword what I already
got wood hmm this thing's being mean to
me I don't like it alright so uhhh I'm
not seeing any animals which is annoying
because I want some foods with some
foods oh I'll have some loading errors
we're not errors necessarily just not
working out okay um as you can see oh I
don't even know where it actually ends
don't lie to me oh also there's new fish
so if we get some string we can make
some some goodies man this the world not
loading is a tad bit annoying
um nice any goodies goodies down there
are not really just caves yeah I Oh
night is descending all right let's
let's build up Shaq I'll build up Shaq
right right here let me just destroy
this sure I destroyed sure all right now
um let's turn some more wood down and
then let's spilled our base of our house
with orange orange orange orange and
let's see if you have enough yeah I had
enough yellow I was gonna say yeah I
feel to go like that I totally do oh
gosh I don't think I do oh I have enough
like that that's good this will be the
front of house and then I can put some
it's just odd and getting red oh no ok
will make you hard and meantime that's
gonna be some double doors and I don't
like that look like that looks alone um
it goes you pop pop pop pop pop those
will be windows in the teacher and let's
throw them a crafting table so we want
to crack ourselves some doors boom boom
and then we can door it up dorda watch
haha and this house is gonna look so
beautiful oh gosh it's really not
looking beautiful I apologize for its
not looking beautifulness and then we're
going to build the roof oh dang it i
hear is that all pubs and II don't let
him in no no out out no no no no
I think I really liked him to drop some
rotten flesh I'm very helpful so I can
make it yeah I can make it boom and then
finish off this orange man this house is
looking at so dang sexy mmm I can't
handle her now so I don't know what to
do hmm let's make a furnace I don't have
any source of food at the moment well I
should also make a chest chest boom all
right furnace let's see I can okay let's
see what I won't get on you I want to
cook some of this sand yeah just just
put that day I don't just take it out
once i'm done hmm and i feel like this
house looking so good ok so if I could
kill some more zombies know why the
world is in load options video settings
I don't I've no idea added a bunch of
innocent as well well I'll just just
straight up glass light right up I
didn't get a piece of it peace nope
longer there if i mix these nope I don't
know how to make stained glass way let's
try something up no no no yes let's cook
something with the remaining fire
I have an idea so let's see all that
didn't even work with come on bro you
can't put red sand and nope you can't
cook I'll jung kim jong-kook class that
way that doesn't work oh mama mama mama
mama I've know he had a oh maybe just
thats and maybe I do Oh ever I may be
out to cook the clay nope can't cook the
clay hey that won't do okay well let's
just click the rest of the wood and make
some torches the exam bambos the spider
don't want a spider that'll definitely
poison me this wise man is well goes
with the terrain at least and I come on
guys it's very nice it's very nice
indeed and third son our charcoal
probably don't need a burn oliver wood
and we can click the rest it with glass
so stick torch a torch a torch
fortunately okay so let's stick and
let's charcoal and let's switch all pro
pro all dying in my house is not
protected fighters get out he bro nope
not your days on our torch torch torch
oh not on torch torch there we go all
right now let's throw all of our goods
in here I want to get rid of the gangs
throw out the window way glass I only
three piece of glass I need cooks more
glass
get a cooking big boy all right for
glass and i will just put you like the
Hat I don't need one more piece on boom
boom boom oh there we go glass glass
just really make a roof huh yeah be a
good idea all right uh yes but also new
fish in this new fish and there are new
new lots of stuff at national exactly
what we're not gonna white for anything
there's enough hardened hmm trying to
think trying to think trying to think I
have an idea okay so so we're gonna
we're going to do this we got this all
right so this one two three now we're
gonna break you and break you I'm go
back boom boom boom boom boom boom pow
and then we're gonna grab a white sauce
boom we're gonna let the like boom and
we're gonna be like we got this we got
this guy's oh yes yes yes yes yes that's
what we do it then we're gonna we're
going to destroy this i'm going to show
you that don't place last leg one right
there and then it's gonna be beautiful i
bet you guys is looking before that oh
gosh it looks so beautiful guys Zuka
check a check all right then maybe we
can make the colors like even once i get
more than alright so i think yeah I
think I'm running at a time in terms of
recording since I need to go do stuff
hmm next time I come back it shall be
daytime and we shall go get food that'll
be a priority number one food or sheep
either one yes and then we'll explore
more of the prettiness of this biome and
maybe a third I can search I can do a
third episode of this and we'll make our
house even better better and then we'll
move on to the next biome so I've heard
there was like some ice pick by almost
sounds delish
and we're going to hit that up so I guys
hope you've enjoyed it if you did make
sure you leave a like rate comment or
subscribe for samuel l jackson and i
will see you all and next time i really
need to think something like unique that
i can say at the beginning the end of
every episode leave suggestions in the
comments of stuff as you say at the
beginning to be chips around the end of
each episode yeah all right yes peace
out
double
the sky